i have pictures of being in your
apartment in new york after
we went to black girls rock and you had
to cut me out of that dress
and we were at your house and the dress
had split the moment i
put it on i guess i was enjoying myself
in life
[Music]
anika it's so good to have you over
thank you i haven't seen you in what
six months it's been about six months
well i'm so glad that we could sit down
it's been so long so we can sit down and
we can just having a conversation
for the academy and let them hear the
way we actually talk about things
hear what happens when the cameras
aren't here exactly
i don't even know if it's fair to ask
people that no i think that question
should be like abolished now i don't
just cry
i'm so glad to see you no really i feel
like i actually feel really giddy
because i had
that's why we when it came on oh my god
you look amazing oh my god
because i've been seeing you in so long
yeah yeah and it's hard because
you know you want to see people yeah and
i miss our our casual
commune way of being but there is no
popping up there is like everything has
to have a plan
no popping up there's no popping up
yeah i've recently i asked some people
how they were and like
asked how family members were who i knew
on two occasions recently and on both
occasions
the people i asked about have passed
away and i said i
and to see their heart
shatter in the answer i said i'm not
asking anymore
i'm not asking how you know no because
that's a big how because i don't want to
crush somebody not because i don't care
or cannot deal with that's right the
comforting
but i'm so many people have lost so many
people like i can't
take them through that right so i want
to ask
we've been arguing about this uh before
the cameras were on but how long have we
known each other
we have known each other you always try
to make it like
30 years 30 years 45 years i would have
been
you know in middle school and you've
been in college
but why am i so old 20 21 years we've
known each other and we keep forgetting
because we were supposed to have
an anniversary party but we did and both
of us were working and we didn't have it
but wait a minute so
what is your recollection of how we
first met we
first met i was uh
performing in robert o'hara's
insurrection holding history at the
geary theater
in san francisco you have these braids
i had amazing brands they were what they
were like super long
they were down to my butt purposefully
for the character that i was playing
and they were like a very urban red
which i wanted um which was no natural
color
on earth and i had just finished the
show and you were
in the i don't know in the receiving
receiving here
saying hello and you were like it's so
nice to meet you and i was like no
no we've met before yeah and i was like
no we haven't no we have
actually we'll figure it out
i've not seen you ever in my life except
when i saw you on stage
but i thought we knew each other it felt
like
it felt like we knew each other and i
and i think that from that moment on
we knew each other right i want to know
how do you make time for all of the
things that you do
like i feel like you move through the
world like there are 35 hours in the day
and how do you is that an active
i need to have a set plan for the day
or is it your special skill like
how do you do that i think i wake up
early as you wake up about 5
30 6 00 in the morning and i like to get
a lot done i think it becomes like my
mother in that way my mother liked to
get everything done by nine
so i may be getting up and running
around doing things in the house home
things
but also taking time to like i don't
know read that's when i get my reading
done
i'll go i will be a night reader so
you're you're not i read in the morning
i feel like i'm popping i get my coffee
and i'll sit and i'll read some scripts
or something or i'll do some writing
all that before anybody's up and then
i sort of just structure it like i don't
know i like that
you've known me most of my career most
of our
and you know that i think i operate best
when i'm working on three or four things
at one time
because i feel like my brain is the kind
of brain that works well when i need to
compartmentalize and focus here i need
to write that and
direct that whatever and i and that
compresses time
otherwise if i think if i have only one
thing to do oh i will procrastinate
that's the worst
that's the worst so i'm glad that you
spoke a little bit about your mom
because you're a production company it's
called edith productions
and a little bit of that answer was part
of a question that i did want to ask you
like how do you
think that edie prepared you
for where you are in this space
i think and not to like deify
a mother or anything like that but i
know that my mother has had a profound
effect on everything that i do i think
that she sent people like you in my life
i think she sends me everything which is
why i have her
name tattooed on me my mother was like
my mother was a true
dreamer and believer and she had faith
she always had questions she was almost
like had a childlike quality to her
was always curious like oh what's that
what are you eating there i want to try
that
so she always she was like oh let's try
that jj she got me jj you know that's my
nickname
so i think that that's how she's
inspired all of this and prepared me for
all of this
the thing for sure that she always
wanted me to
live in gratitude for everything
everything is giving honor to
to spirit whatever you want to call it
and so i think that's how i sort of
operate
in the world and operate in the world
she always said this this
is i'll never forget this and you tell
me because my mom when i moved to san
francisco
and i was you know trying to be out
there and being an actor
and the conversation we were having the
phone i guess i was talking about myself
a lot
and she was like you need to go
volunteer or something you know find
something
to do with your time and i was like okay
[ __ ]
you're really good with kids can you go
volunteer with kids somewhere
i found a school where i was an
after-school program teacher and i was
never more fulfilled which is why i
always teach
i always got to keep some teaching
because they realize it makes you feel
purposeful
and she said she said why because it's
not about you
always keep something in your life
that's not about you and that's how you
will actually
make it through this world and so i do
that you know what i mean
i feel like she imbued you with so much
love
but she also taught you how to give
that love and i think that that's
something that you
express not only in your work and your
acting
but in your life which allows your work
to be an extension of that which is
funny because i feel like we don't
really talk about work
much at all together it's wild
we never there are times when people are
like well what's anika doing i have no
idea why she's there
like what's she what is she doing in
canada right now i'm like
a show i think the name is called this
but we focus on life but see honestly i
feel like you and i have been able to
navigate
this industry and look look at us we're
21 years strong as friends
but because the thing that i had a
problem with when i moved out here to be
honest was when people were like
i'm like hey i would love to see you i
would love to get together we'll have to
meet your
kid or whatever oh well i'm going to
have an event and
i don't i didn't say event i didn't
that's not what i do i'm not there for
your event i'm there to actually
have a connection with you yeah and
actually
and you i want that but but i feel like
we you and i have been really
great proponents of making sure that
that's real you know well i don't
how do you know i'm not good at the
other thing
i'm glad you said it you're not good at
that i'm not good
that's not your spirit i wish that i
were better at it i may
i would maybe have a much better career
um and i'm not downing my career because
i'm
grateful for it i just know that
i have only so much energy
for that part but you kind of also like
you're i i think of you as like i mean
the the woman that i see out there in
red carpets empty i know you're very
sort of at home quiet one-on-one person
like you you live in the one-on-one in
the real connections and like
going for a hike going for a walk
usually somewhere out of nature
you know what i mean you're like it
almost feels like diametrically opposed
to the other stuff that we have to be
well i think it sort of is and and you
know
i'm i'm a virgo i'm a virgo leo so
i really believe like that leo is the
space where you hit the carpet like
you know or you're on stage
but the virgo is like okay now we're
gonna
let me put my onesie on let's see that's
what every time you come
come over here you either you come out
over here papa with an entrance outfit
or and then you but then you usually
steal my sweats
i have pictures of being in your
apartment in new york after
we went to black girls rock and you had
to cut me out of that dress
and i was wait wait i feel like you're
barefoot on the streets too i was
barefoot on the street
after the show because those trolls were
ten minute shoes
and we had been there over an hour and i
don't believe in ugly feet
so i don't believe in wearing shoes
longer than they say they should be worn
so they were off and we were at your
house and the dress had split
the moment i put it on i guess i was
enjoying myself in life
which means a meal um but it split
and so they had to sew it on me and i
looked very cute
when i got to your house and i couldn't
get it off wow
you were trying to cut me out of this
dress so i was there like glammed
jewelry your sweat some socks up to my
knee
and living in my comfort space and
that's how i like to be
and i i think that i think that i'm
misunderstood
actually quite often i think that people
may think something about
me because i also have a naturally
downturned
mouth so people think that i look chewy
smiling
turned is it well no oh it's a little
downturn it has a little down turn but
it doesn't naturally go is that is that
they call resting
is that resting [ __ ] it's not resting
[ __ ] face no no i don't know
you don't have wrestling [ __ ] face but
i don't i think that
i think that people assume
something about me because when i'm down
or
silent i think i look i'm very closed
or i appear very close and then we smile
it's so open and then
we have a connection right and then
perhaps you get to know
who i am but i do think that i i can be
misunderstood in that way and really
what it is is i'm an introvert
basically that's basically what we're
getting around this thing i'm like
you're basically an introvert
and you're with it and you're an
extroverted tendency and you always hang
out with an extrovert and i hang out
with a social butterfly
so then people get confused they're like
okay so wait but yeah yeah now i'm gonna
ask you some other questions since we're
we're having this conversation for our
friends
um and i want to talk about some things
that i think that
it's it's a conversation i know that we
have had and i think we we continue to
have
about are we able to discern
critique our own work
as um in this industry what do you mean
by your our own whose own
who's on let's say black people because
i feel like right now
only because i have this conversation
just like last week i wonder and i
question sometimes are we able to
because we have such uh
we're still still always trying to move
the needle when it comes to
representation when it comes to black
film
and black people let them know i don't
want to say just black men but black
people are eating them though
can we discern can we critique or
sometimes
i find myself wanting to pull away from
a criticism of something because you
want it to be there
you want it to exist you want more
opportunities but then sometimes you
just want to be like but that's not
great
that's not the best level of what we can
actually be or to interrogate the work
in that way
and then you feel like am i just being
not cool i'm like you want to be cool
but you're like
i want the work to be incredible and i
want us to be able to really
have a forum for it so i've been having
these conversations with people
wondering like how do we feel can we do
it when can we do it
i am of the opinion that if we are
honest in a critique
then the space that is there will be a
space for something better
right but i think even on a larger level
you know critics and this
probably is controversial i think that
some critics are afraid
to honestly critique the work of people
of color
i agree and i think that that fear lies
in thinking they're going to be called
racist
if they didn't like something and i
don't think
disliking something makes you racist
right i think the way in which you
the way in which you look at it or
examine it the way in which you lay it
out there the language that you use
yeah may if it may be they bring that to
you
it may come up you have to look at
yourself and figure out how you're
speaking
right um and and did you stay in one
place
while film art people culture moved
forward
um but another part of that conversation
is that there are not enough
critics who are people of color
absolutely who know from which
they are speaking culturally yes um
and i think that anybody can say
this was skillful or this was not if
they have the right
base yeah from which to come but
you know there are people critiquing
things just well i didn't like it well
that's not a critique
right and you know what else is not a
critique and what we end up with
oftentimes is the blogger who just tells
you
everything that happened in the movie
right that's not a critique
that's you giving me a synopsis yeah so
i i think that i think criticism has to
be re-examined actually
i was
has to change it has to open
to more people it has to be taught but i
think that when we think of the word
criticism even immediately we think it's
something negative
criticism should be an
analysis absolutely of something and
it's okay to say
how something made you feel because art
is supposed to make you feel something
but i need people to come from some sort
of educated space
before they tear something down that
they don't understand at all
or laud something that they don't
understand at all
because now you've done us a disservice
i want to know who would you love
to work with who would i like to work
with who you have at work you've worked
with some amazing and fantastic people
but who you've not worked with yeah and
they don't have to be like
amazing and fantastic in like you know
they're on time 100
but to you to me
i feel like i really get in i love
working with like
younger filmmakers new filmmakers people
who are like wanting to
disrupt the forum and stuff like like
working with jenixa bravo
or working with them i just worked with
numa perrier
and um i don't know i feel like young
women i think is always i feel like i'm
drawn to young women uh uh so they're
strong and interesting and
and i don't know i feel like janix is
like cassavetes and i feel like
she's so interesting and she's awesome
ordinarily funny yeah
on instagram yeah we worked together but
it was so tiny
that i feel like we need to do something
else because that wasn't that was tiny
what about you who i was thinking
i i guess i would love to work with
anjanu ellis
i just think she's like why don't the
strangest thing is maybe because i've
worked with her so many times i felt
like you've worked with her already i
have because i
i just like her at home
a lot i'm just putting it out there and
what she did
on that clark sisters mini series which
is that nobody talked about
she needed to she needed some sort of
nomination for that because it was
epic absolutely
some one of the best performances of
this year it was beautiful it was
beautiful i'm going to ask you an
academy-based
uh question yes we you became a member
of the academy
three years ago four i told you
about me and time oh yeah
i don't know we both became members i
became after you i became
right after you right after me and i
called you because i was like
i would like to nominate you you were
like oh so already nominated me
is that my voice is that how sound is
that that's how it felt
that's already nominated so
we are still very um sort of uh
you know at the beginning of our um
journey
journey with the academy what are your
hopes for the academy and what what can
we do
and how can we be a part of it and make
some changes
besides things like this right
which is fantastic
i think i would like when covid releases
us i would like for the academy
to be able to be a space
that is more connective yeah
i agree i would very much like that
there are people
that i would love to learn from yeah um
who i never meet and you know if you're
at like
an awards tea or banquet or something
like that
there there are too many things
happening there's too much energy
running through that
people feel like this yeah like they're
stupid you should have managed the night
they're trying to get through
you know and deal with their 10 minute
heels then it's been an hour
um so i would love for the academy to
become more
connective i would like more of this
with with academy members i would like
more like i would like this i feel like
more times when we can just throughout
the year be in a room together
with people you don't know with people
you don't know not just people people
who like
hey maybe you know there's you know i'm
sure there's committees and
subcommittees and things like that but
just like hey i want to talk about this
thing and
talk about how do we make our industry a
bit more you know equitable and
inclusive you know i would love the
opportunity i know
the academy does mentorship for young
people
outside of what we do who are trying to
start doing what we do i would love to
explore
mentorship within the academy that's
pretty like
what director can i sit up under
and and learn from because i want to
direct at some point and i
and it's a fantastic idea i don't want
to
have to bug somebody i'm working with in
the time that we're working together be
like hey
so how'd you do that yeah you can go you
know you'll work with somebody exactly
there's mentorship
i would very much in the academy within
the academy that's fantastic
um like crossing branches cross
branches to do that and i think it would
be a really cool thing and i think it
would strengthen us all
as artists to to be perfectly honest
i mean this may be overstepping but
maybe
the academy can create and i don't know
if there is one and
so forgive me if i'm speaking out of
turn fellow members
a um
a class on criticism hmm
teach young people about criticism about
criticism
and how to yeah how to analyze
i think it's fantastic um so that when
somebody does put their
hearts work on a screen people can and
look i'm not saying that
there are great critics there are lots
of great critics
i'm saying to make sure that we bring up
a generation
of new critics who aren't just giving
you a synopsis
to teach them what that means and how
that works and
from the inside so that they understand
how much work goes into putting
something together well
i think this has been nice i think let's
just just leave it there this is a good
conversation to have i love talking to
you
me too i've missed you so much i missed
you too
and i just feel like we've everybody
been in exile so this is exactly what i
needed
and i'm really happy to see you i love
you i am so
proud honored happy
um and completed by being able to call
you
my friend my family and i thank you
thank you i love you and i feel the same
way
hi i'm coleman domingo hi i'm anika noni
rose
and for more conversation please
subscribe to the
oscars youtube channel
you